what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're going to watch the
next episode of The Last of Us of course
joined by my incredibly sexy handsome
beautiful gorgeous friend Andrew the
Gordon Igor 7-Eleven hello beautiful
that was uh that was nice I know you
understood that reference
ladies and gentlemen you know what to do
leave a like on this video I want to say
thank you to everyone who's been
watching our videos uh it means the
world it means a lot to have everyone
here but before we go into that reaction
we do have a sponsor today a sponsor who
I intentionally wanted to shout out on
the Last of Us video because these are
the perfect items for anyone to survive
in the middle of an apocalypse or if you
just want to be a cool Woodsman and that
is the company bespoke you know bespoke
is Andrew let me tell you bespoke post
is a monthly membership club delivering
a box of awesome top shelf goods from
under the radar Brands it's free to join
and you can skip a month or cancel at
any time so every month they introduce
members to cool new products uh talking
outdoor gear Hardware home and kitchen
goods clothing and more even live
oysters you're always asking me about
live oysters Andrew and it's all based
on a preference quiz that they fill out
so 90 of the products that come from
small Brands I like small Brands Andrew
I hope you do too many of which are
based right here in the US of a that's
where we live Andrew every box of
awesome has around 70 worth of goods
inside but costs you only a fraction of
the value now I got three boxes myself
Andrew I got three boxes myself I saw
this on the bespoke side I said I want
that throwing knives that's right baby
look at that it comes with a full grain
leather sheath they're throwing knives
for any skill level 18 by 18 tough
targets face this one I saw too because
I was like this would really come in
handy it's an mh10 headlamp it helps you
not be afraid to hike at night when
you're lost in the darkness Greg look
for the light oh you tied it in thank
you Andrew and the last one this is one
that I was like for a guy who goes on
road trips quite a lot I really needed
this one almost as much as I needed
throwing knives A Day Tripper cooler bag
and it comes with a stainless steel
bottle opener as well you'll be able to
preview your box of Ford shift what I
mean by that is you'll get a box of
awesome assigned to you and before it's
shipped you'll get a preview of what's
to come inside to decide if you'd like
to one keep it two swap it for a
different box or three skip the month
entirely for no charge you only pay for
what you want so to get 20 off your
first box of awesome click the link in
the description box and at checkout use
the code real rejects 20. or go to
bespoke.com real rejects 20. thank you
to bespoke for sponsoring this video
foreign
good for you guys
holy God
[Music]
oh these are uh these are Hunters
oh is this the night they escaped whoa
he's hearing impaired either they're
just being silent just because I don't
want to get caught did it feel good the
train your neighbors to Federal
how does it make you feel now and they
really give a villain to the hunters huh
we could put you on trial you're all
guilty so that's how that'll go and
you'll do something
do something easy where is Henry
I guess they don't know kill them he's
with edel's Team oh man hey I want our
people going door to door no oh I'm
sorry how long do you think we should
wait should we wait a day or two should
we wait a week door-to-door take a lot
of men and there are other things he's
not my seventh priority Perry come on
Perry get with the program we are not
really putting them on trial
when you're done burn the bodies it's
bad
oh
damned well losing a family member uh
can do that to you I guess
foreign
they're gonna die before they get to
meet Ellie
[Laughter]
scared
yeah of course he is he's scared because
you're scared
he's always had to protect him
oh the gay music
foreign
just always properly know when to insert
the music from the game
I like seeing this because in the game
like Henry's just so Stern and
disciplinary with Sam to like keep him
alive do you get to see this really soft
side
we must have overlapped at the previous
episode
this is so smart that we're getting to
spend some time with Henry and Sam
before they meet Joel Nelly
speak sign language don't you I do my uh
best friend is
dealing with the reality yeah
I'll become a superhero
ah
okay this makes sense
clever
oh man it's so much harder to survive in
this when you're hearing impaired yeah
foreign
from that angle
duck yeah I like the perspective ships
yeah goes specifically looking for them
glass
smart are you sure you're gonna hear it
of course I'll hear it that's the damn
point we don't want to hurt you we want
to help you
okay okay um
I don't know what the next step is with
something like this
you heard us
right
that's right oh wow so weird it's all
man that's just the way he sounds he has
an [__] voice don't tell him he's
okay
everything's great dude
I can't read your tone man my name is
Henry
My Brother Sam
and Most Wanted Man in Kansas City
although right now my guesses are
running a close second
yeah they already think they're working
together
I switched locations as they mentioned
did you get these from Bill
and she is
how old is he
[Laughter]
DJ oh that's young I'm Ellie you're like
12 in the game yeah something like I
mean in the game he said he was 14 and
then Sam made fun of him for saying that
or Henry did I mean
look
[Laughter]
I saw what you did
he killed those men
never killed anyone
I'm pointing I know they're gonna choose
the closest I've ever come to being
violent
my shoulder weight
you clear the way
survived this long without killing
anyone
not even infected
[Music]
in a long time
so how are we getting now
uh definitely a change from the game no
[__] version we get close we get
caught how do we get across
it's a great plan so what do you need me
for
oh that was infected
just not on the surface Frederick drove
them underground 15 years ago you
see what I know is
it's empty you've been down there how do
you know that no but the federal guy
that I worked with told me that it's
clean yeah what if there's more or one
of those blind ones that seems like a
bat wait
you ran into a clicker the first thing I
call a clicker in the show yeah maybe
yeah if it gets bad down there we turn
around and run right back out the scene
where we can oh that's a great plan no
that's my dicey is plan
but as far as I could tell
only shot I like him a lot he's great
you're saying they're going to help us
Escape
dope
right
oh we also saw last episode what's
possibly under there goodness
[Music]
I like this a lot it's extremely
immediate
site
I think it's his way
I just love how exhausted he is from
running plays into the age a lot more
I just got a smile on her face
shoot something
[Music]
exciting episode damn
oh God yeah gee it's empty is good I
wouldn't risk talking
we've been down here
down here don't know anything
about my dad
oh wow
oh my God what a shot
really make the perspective feel like
trapping you know claustrophobic too
yeah I could have just said that
oh the amazing yeah oh my God just like
ah
nice nice attention to detail
yep yep
oh no way no way no way in dude I bet
Ellie would like that
four five six eleven
ah so cool
it's cute to the edge of the U -verse
and back
endure
survive [__] yeah man
it wouldn't be so bad to wait light out
a bit different that was when we pop
back out on the other side
you can tell he's not comfortable with
that
yes
original
four and about me not killing someone
yeah yeah it was a man a great man and
he's always forgiving have you ever met
someone like that
kind of man you'd follow anywhere
Sam you got sick leukemia there was one
drug that worked there wasn't much left
of it
belong to Federal so I gave them
something big
oh that one great man
interest yeah I am the bad guy because I
did a bad guy thing when you get it
though
you might not be her father
but you were someone's yeah
that's
smart for many reasons that we can't get
into I will say yeah that's like all
we're gonna say
Gamers know what we're talking about
that's all we'll say I do really like
the guy who's playing Henry though he's
really good feels very real yeah you
feel the weight of everything on his
shoulders
we were together we would be safe
soft side to the coldness he was so
beautiful I'm not
never was
the last time I saw him alive in a jail
he told me to forgive
yeah
where is the Justice in that what is the
point of that
very good question your brother was a
great man we all loved him he didn't
change anything you did that's why they
follow you we're with you
good it's interesting that
without going into any story details at
all that they are carrying over themes
from the second game I was thinking just
that
oh so they they just made it through the
tunnels already yeah that was fast where
are you gonna go I don't know yet
well we're going to Wyoming
what it's a huge state it can fit two
more people
maybe we just call this one a success
and say our father was changed his mind
this is how it goes he's like no L.A
nervous
and then I'm like I'm gonna ask you a
million more times
[Music]
a sniper yep
night time yep change the setting of the
day
oh [__]
guys
you would know better Henry come on if
you don't move
he's not gonna hit you I'm gonna go
around
try to get nails through the back and
then I'll take them out but if you go
out there he's gonna kill you
oh you trust me
I love how worried Ellie got for him
when he said he was gonna move
the sound design that sniper is crazy he
is moving along briskly here look at him
go
[Music]
just alone the sniper is waiting all
night
[Music]
oh as an old ass man ah Put the gun down
slide it over to me
and then stay up here for another hour
this dude looks so familiar please don't
do it please
uh
it's got a sniper yeah
that made a lot of noise
no
oh
I was like just please don't skip out on
this part yeah
why do you think you're in front clear
them
oh my God they're gonna Mad Max this
[__]
[Music]
holy God
yeah no need to shoot Ellie just kiss
run
wow that is terrifying
no
[Music]
nicely done Joe
[Applause]
[Music]
damn look at that wreckage
holy crap
[Music]
whoa
thank God that happened
ah
is that a rumble they've made so much
noise
gosh she's such a pain in the ass she's
not the kids go oh
no
sorry
I know why you did what you did but did
you ever stop to think that maybe he was
supposed to die man will kids die Henry
they die all the time
annoying
what's gonna happen it ends the way it
ends
oh
let's go
[Music]
oh take your shot Joel
oh God that is scary
oh you can hear all of them
oh
whoa
wow
there's so many
[Applause]
[Music]
nice yeah oh cool wow this is chaotic as
hell
oh deeper alive
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
is this it
whoa oh
[Music]
come on
oh man motor is gonna be right for him
oh
oh goodbye Jeffrey Pierce probably
watered a gnarly death
oh my God is that a child it looks like
it
come on Ellie you got a gun
I think she's out of ammo
where's Henry Sam okay
[Music]
oh I love that POV perspective this is
great
what a scary ass situation of being oh
[Applause]
damn
man you gotta be a really confident shot
to make sure you don't shoot out where'd
that bloater go
this [__] woman man
uh
oh
[Music]
good oh there's the bloated
damn
wow that is like a World War Z effect
whoa never in the game did we see that
many you didn't throw any spores
that was a night wasn't it it'll be okay
easier when you're a kid anyway
is it you don't have anybody else
relying on you I guess you're doing a
good job then
dear and survive that's just redundant
yeah it's not great
look I don't know exactly how I'm
getting to Wyoming I'm probably walking
you know if you want to yeah oh the bond
oh it's like you're waiting to hear that
again
oh
to line up look scared
this kid is a really good actor
scorpions
that's a fear but before the apocalypse
people have
um
uh oh he's gonna tell her oh wow what a
change
wow my blood is medicine
oh this is so sad
oh my God
it's worth a try
true
this is a really interesting angle oh
that is so heartbreaking
just wants to heal him
[Music]
oh
this is even more gut-wrenching
amen
promise
God damn you freaking invited them to my
office get everything
hey
laughs
holy [__] are you okay
what what did I do
oh my God
let me know
and Ally probably really thought it
worked too huh [__] just this whole
world shattered Henry
that that was harsh
which was West
kind of does feel out of Logan
Hall
[Music]
s
oh boy what'd you think Andrew I'll just
check it out kick it off kicking them
off you kick it off I thought it was a
really well paced jumble of emotion
episode where you know the the tone was
really well balanced and just I mean
there were moments of exhilaration from
the action to just more moments of heart
wrench and then moments of bond and I
really love the angle too I mean we're
going to talk about a lot of different
things but I really love the angle they
went out with Sam and Ellie I mean it
was a little bit different perspective
to me how I felt in the game was Sam
kind of had a little bit of a crush on
Ellie and you know that was and that's
at least how I took it definitely um but
I thought the the talks in the game yeah
oh yeah that too um but I thought this
was really unique you know having him
being hearing impaired and you know they
had more of a a older sister little
brother type of bond and I just it was
very heartfelt and I really appreciated
the chemistry between uh belly and and
salmon I thought they the scenes were
just so emotional on I also love how you
pointed out to that you know Henry had a
little bit because in the game he's very
he's very Stern very strict
understandably so he doesn't want
anything to happen to say I'm in a
post-apocalyptic world we can all
understand that but seeing the softer
side of their relationship I I thought
it was really endearing and I
appreciated seeing that but there were
just a lot of different things I know
you mentioned that Kathleen was very
annoying and I agree there were moments
where I'm like damn it why do you keep
interrupting here and I get it but I I
did think you know they did a good job
of at least making me feel empathetic
towards her I mean I I did feel for her
I I feel terrible that you know Sam had
to do the make the moral decision like
hey um do I give up this man that I that
I really deeply care for and respect and
you know he's a big part of this
resistance movement that's going to help
us from fedra but it's to save you know
my world my my brother which I'm not
going to go into possible foreshadowing
but um I I just think it was a really
interesting moral dilemma to give us
that something from the game we didn't
really get to see much of from Henry I
mean was just more of uh hey let's go
out of this uh let's get out of
Pittsburgh situation I'm gonna do
whatever it takes to save my brother
that's the extent of what we got from
Henry in in the game so I think they
gave you know they made him a much more
in my opinion three more uh
three-dimensional character in in this
episode and I really appreciated you
know the layers that they gave this
character and I thought the actor who
played I mean I think all the actors did
a great job in this episode the actor
who played Henry he was great you could
see how broken he was from the decision
he had to make but you know again you
could empathize with his decision
because he was saving his brother's life
so I just I thought they did a lot of
really interesting angles and we got him
in bloater yeah that was freaking
awesome oh man they really nailed it
with that I know it was a little sad
that he didn't throw the spores or
whatever but whatever I mean it was it
was so cool to see him bloated in live
action that was awesome but yeah no I
mean this was a great episode and also
seeing you know the belly and Joel uh
relationship getting more fleshed out I
really appreciate that just again little
nuances and moments like where you know
the sniper is cornering them and Joel is
saying I'm gonna go around here and now
he's like no no you could get hit like
just little things like that it just
adds a big you know layer to their
relationship and I like how it's slowly
being fleshed out it's just ah I'm so
invested in those two they're so good
together yeah I mean like the The Last
of Us video game the first one is pretty
short yes for a video game in comparison
to the second one too yeah but it's
still longer than Nine episodes of
Television will be you know what I mean
yeah like it's still going to be longer
than that
um because so much of the storytelling
does advance as part of the game like if
you only watch just the cutscenes their
story that's intertwined in diet like a
lot of the dialogue where you're like
that's what they say in the game it's
probably that's happening while you're
doing gameplay a lot of the time so you
know it's like you can't like Infuse
everything uh into here understandably
so and I think that the you know the
themes that they leave with that
resonate so strong of you know the the
consequences of what we do for love and
you know they start talking about
forgiveness here and so much of this of
the world of loss of us it just
primarily I think deals with with the
topic of consequences you know uh like
having this thing with Henry where
he he made a choice
um and now there's just massive
consequences to it you know and the the
ultimate it's so it's just so
so loud
for sure to have
you know because it's like of course I
remembered that in in the game obviously
you know yeah uh Sam does get um
attacked and he does but he keeps it a
secret yeah and I like this and then and
then Henry ends up having to kill his
brother and then um we'll say unalives
himself because YouTube's sensitive
about a certain word uh but the way I
went down here did have a little bit
more of a realistic approach
um but yeah it does have it has that
thing about it I I I I think that you
know drugman sometimes likes to refuse
them how can we break their hearts more
of hey let's have Joe welcome them to go
to Wyoming the moment before we learn
that Sam's infected hey let's see yeah
Sam will keep infected but let's have
him tell Ellie and have Ellie hope that
her blood will actually cure this guy
that was a really interesting angle I'd
love that yeah it add it does add that
Dimension to it
um because yeah you in the it's it it
this show has an interesting
contrasts uh to to the game because
in some ways you spend more time with
Henry and Sam in the game but in a lot
of ways you get to know Henry and Sam a
lot more in the show Absolutely within
the this one hour episode that they have
so it's it's very it's very interesting
how they do that because let's no no no
no I was listening no I felt like you
wanted to say something I want you to be
able to say stuff Andrew no no no keep
going keep going all right I think I'll
keep going
anyway yeah they have so so I like what
they're doing with Henry and I liked
what they did with Henry and Sam here a
lot
and how like the encounters that Joel
has
I think there's like a a I think the arc
you guys obviously even if you haven't
played the game I think the the obvious
Arc of Joel getting in touch with his
fatherhood side while bonding with Ellie
is extremely apparent even if you
haven't played right you just spoiled it
for me man you know like that's that's
obvious
um and what I'm liking is this sort of
uh Nomad approach that the show's taking
well this Wanderer where as you're on
the roads of travels you have an
encounter like oh he gets this letter
from Bill and that affects him and that
kind of plays into that Arc
he encounters Henry and Sam and through
dialogue exchanges that he has there
that affects him that it plays into that
Arc and I think that's really neat how
they develop that because
you don't have as much time as a game so
they find ways of okay well how can we
make certain scenes more substantial
so that way we can still have that
desired effect that we're looking for
because I did have I did I did fine I
I've never in the it took five episodes
for me to get here
um five in total where I found myself
going ah you skipped over some stuff
that I really would have liked to have
seen in live action the tunnel scene I
mean yeah the the tunnel scene and uh
just just some like overall sneaking
sequences you know like there's it's
like significantly more complex
um you know when he's having to sneak to
the sniper yeah yeah yeah like a whole
bunch of people and stuff yeah I'm like
okay you kind of just like like ran back
there it got up there yeah you know uh
and so I I do um I I do find myself
um that I do find my that was the one
this was the first episode where I would
find myself actually thinking that way
more than the bill and Frank episode
because for some reason I think it's
because in the bill and Frank episode
there was almost like nothing that was
from the kid so it didn't really uh make
me think about the game when I was
watching that episode whereas here there
were stuff where I was like really
thinking about the game and then I found
myself kind of missing some stuff that
they skipped out on so it does have to
be a little bit of a mental check for
myself to go that's different that's the
game this is the show how is the show
doing it and I thought show was handling
it really well because I actually think
the the way the sequence went like when
he shot
um when Henry had to kill his brother
here
uh this
I like how they they
he doesn't have time to think about it
you know
it it they don't play into this like big
rumination conflict of like what do I do
what do I do what do I do it's just like
such a fraught tense situation
that is just it's like it's all off
Instinct in that moment and you shoot
and then and then it's a realization of
like what have I done which is kind of
like how it does in the game but it but
it's it's played it was something I felt
more
realistic to me in this scenario
um so yeah I think that they they really
hit it here the thing with the one thing
I'll say is the thing with Kathleen
there's just something about her that I
wasn't truly interested in and I and I
have no idea like it was one of those
things where yeah I I you're doing all
the things that I would like a show to
do if you're bringing in this character
and you're you're flushing them out
you're giving them more Humanity you're
giving them more layers it was this
weird thing for me where I just I found
myself going I feel like on paper
everything to make me click with this
idea of having this character here and
what you're doing should make me
interested in her but I'm really not I
have no idea why I I just wasn't in tune
I don't know if it was the performance I
don't like the dog performers but I
don't know if it was the performance
um it it just was something that I
preferred it when you would just check
in with her and she was like
just a villain and and uh like the the
with it with the um with the tinge of
humanity like the last episode where you
could tell like oh this is rooted in the
pain of losing her brother yeah yeah
like that that stuff but I did really
like that scene though with her and
Jeffrey Pierce explaining about you know
the forgiveness and her brother and all
that and saying I don't care about that
because it does play a lot into some
themes that I can't go into with
foreshadowing about revenge and losing
your humanity and just what that can do
to you so I did you know from that
perspective it was told Neil druckman
told The Last of Us I appreciated from
that perspective but I I hear what
you're saying you're just more used to
seeing her as a stalker for Charlie
Sheen on Two and a Half Men yeah it must
be like you're not funny what's going on
yeah no I mean but that's the thing with
that it was that scene when it really
hit me when I'm like
I really feel like I should be more
interested in what's happening but I
kind of just want to cut back to the
other stuff right now yeah fair enough
yeah fair enough fair enough but uh and
to your point I do find her believable I
I mean if I have to be
really honest like I I guess I just
didn't find her all that believable no
there were there were points too where I
was agreeing with you was a little like
this character is annoying but again I I
understood her motivations I I could
sympathize with her I get where she's
coming from I can't say you know if
someone again we know that uh Henry
didn't murder her brother but he
basically like laid him out in the lamb
you know to to fedra so I I get where
her anger stems from my I could
understand that from a character
perspective but I get what you're saying
there were just times where like all
right I'm I'm kind of done with this
checked out I just wanna I just want to
go back to Henry Sam Joel and and belly
and let's let's get let's get hopefully
a bloater in here somewhere so I I could
sympathize with what you're saying but
um to what you were saying earlier you
made a really good point because we
definitely got it felt like at least in
the video game when it comes to Sam and
Henry we got to spend more time with
them at least because there's an
extended tunnel sequence that we got
like maybe five minutes here yeah and
then sneaking around the guards and yeah
yeah but so I I get you're totally right
when it comes to that but again I I
appreciate that we got more character
moments we got to know them more and
that's what I I loved what I've loved
that whole tunnel sequence hell yeah
probably would have cost a lot of money
too to to include those sequences so I I
get where they're they're taking
shortcuts and I appreciate what Neil
druckman said like hey if it makes sense
in our story we're gonna stick exactly
at the game for the most part if it if
it's something that we can improve upon
we're gonna do that and for the most
part they've pretty much nailed that
down and I've loved everything that
they've included or got rid of um I I
can appreciate what you're saying in
terms of that snipe because in the game
that's sniper sequence there's so much
ten I mean when you got just the few
guys coming out after you and then
that's I mean it takes a good five to
ten minutes even if you're really good
at that game to to get in there and I'm
not saying we needed to spend that much
time yeah in the in the game you are
you're Joel and you're you're and you're
trying to get Henry Sam and Ellie to get
to you yeah and you have to keep
shooting down bad guys I keep coming
yeah but I mean again I I do like the
changes overall throughout the uh what
is that five episodes we watched
throughout the five episodes I think
they've made smart changes and expanded
where they need to and again the whole
angle of I still love the episodes
if you have I'm not calling nitpicks but
it's things that like hey I just I was
thinking about this in the game no it's
fair what you're making Fair points and
you know yeah it's better to be the only
one yeah yeah no no for sure but uh and
I mean the action like finally we got a
really action-packed episode I mean I
know we got at the beginning of episode
four we got to see uh Joel and belly
like uh unloading on on the uh Hunters
but the action we got like I mean at
least for me I don't remember ever in
the game that many amount of infected
coming at once so well it's like they I
like that because it was like a hive
mind was just building up in there just
waiting to break out yeah and so it's
like a cool crescendo yeah and it's I
like the ironic part of it was these
guys who pushed them all under the
tunnels and now it's come back to
swallow yeah and we saw that
foreshadowing obviously at the uh at the
at some point in the last episode we saw
the rumble and we're like oh is that
what we think it is yeah so and because
she didn't prepare for it yeah yeah
no it makes sense came back to eat her
alive yeah at literally and figures and
the imagery too I don't know maybe I'm
crazy I mean I am crazy but uh the
imagery reminded me a lot of Steven
Summers uh the mummy and The Mummy
Returns when the scarabs just come out
like you said it just reminded me a lot
of that so but no overall great episode
um I really liked the two actors who
played Henry and Sam that was uh I just
was I mean obviously I was already
emotionally invested in the characters
from the game but obviously different
things seeing him on the TV show and
right away in one episode is hooked I
love the way they inserted the
non-linear storytelling from the
beginning back to their perspective from
what was happening in the last episode
it reminded me yeah it remind me me a
lot of Man of Steel and Batman v
Superman the end of Man of Steel and
then seeing it from Bruce Wayne's
perspective at the beginning of Batman
vs Superman just seeing those different
perspectives uh intersecting
intertwining rather so I thought that
was a really neat and interesting touch
but overall yeah I love this episode it
really did a good job of just balancing
so many different things you felt
exhilarated from the action you felt
really heartbroken and gut-wrenched from
not only what happened to uh to Sam and
Henry but like
you could tell with belly that it really
like not only broke her a little bit
that she just like she just started
bonding not only with Sam and Henry but
she thought like she had something that
could save him and then just the the
heart wreck of no not being able to so
it's just oh she feels like she's got to
have more of a purpose to what's
happening absolutely so I just I thought
this this episode just did a great job
of hitting on so many different levels
from action to emotion to heartbreak to
it was just and really well paced it was
just a very
exhilarating episode that I really
appreciated and loved I know the trailer
without gonna be very careful I know the
trailer show because they mentioned the
character Riley in the first episode and
I know the trailer shows you Riley
um like she's created on IMDb uh so you
know you gotta see what's happened with
Riley what was that whole story right
like they gotta explore that at some
point in the show
and
I'm trying to figure out how to
formulate my words and saying this
I think like the the story of Riley that
they hinted at in the first one
um in the first episode
it was neat to see that they that they
still infused the whole thing of Henry
uh Sam and and Ellie bonding
and
it kind of reminds me of what I remember
from
the stuff with Riley and Gabe that's
also I guess that's the best not spoiler
away I'm just I don't know you know what
I mean I don't know how to formulate
without spoiling so I'm just gonna say I
agree with you yeah yeah but yeah and
and
because of that that even added to a
layer for that that was one of the crazy
benefits of having played the game
is because of that that even makes the
bonding with
um you know uh Sam even more
heartbreaking uh
yeah that's all I don't know about it
guys that was I gotta tell you that was
beyond entertaining watching Greg like
just really carefully how do I want to
say this without really spoiling too
much that was good that was that was
hard I know we got to explain I know we
got to be careful because we've already
been accused a few times of spoiling
stuff just from the most ridiculous
things but yeah but no it's it's um this
this this in particular one was great
and um yeah I don't understand why Perry
I look at Perry the Perry that um
Jeffrey Pierce yeah you just just run
and it's just like
that loader's coming for me I'm gonna
run dude come on Jeffrey Pierce is like
I gotta have a an epic death by bloater
I meant it felt like that kind of thing
where it's like if I'm gonna be a new
show you better give me an epic death
yeah for sure but it was no from a
character's perspective like it's a damn
bloater like run dude run oh yeah it's
like dude run or throw some fire at one
of the two
um but uh yeah I'm like he's gonna get
rid of you in a second like if you're
not like buying her much time
um
and yeah and yeah that was that was
crazy that was a crazy sequence it was a
cool Crescendo of of sort of a whole
array of all these kind of crazy things
but yeah no and just really quick from
the that final trailer we got where we
got to see the bloater and we saw a few
infected like coming out from from the
uh from the fire of that house I I
didn't think there was going to be this
many infected so that was a nice yeah
yeah there was a night there were a lot
of nice surprises in this episode so I
was just I was really happy uh from a
gamer perspective and from just good
damn uh episode of Television I was
really happy
I do think that sometimes even I think
even from like a television stamp even
it sometimes it is a little bit
challenging to assess
um like the only thing we do is be
honest about it sometimes it can be a
challenging to assess like how would I
feel about this moment if like without
the game right
um because it sometimes it does feel
like there were parts of the pacing that
did feel off to me at times during this
episode and I'm not and the thing is
like I'm not entirely sure if it's just
because I'm like it just feel like a cut
down version of what I know I think
that's what it was because I I was kind
of thinking in my head okay wow the
tunnel sequence was really cut down and
then the going right to the sniper
there's like build up to stuff and yeah
and then there's not much tension and
yeah and then it's like there's this
whole swarm of people then they just
find a place to like it just cuts to
them they're hiding someplace you know I
get what I get what you're saying
because sometimes I get the impression
this show has the approach of like I
don't want any fat no fat here no fat
like no [__] here like no fat at and
then there are other times I'm like well
now I feel like we kind of just
skip to the scene or or or just rush to
this moment but it was only in this
episode where I felt that at like
certain points right it's not like the
whole thing yeah it's like very very
minimal at certain points but yeah
because I did I found it interesting
when you made the comment when they were
outside after the song like oh they're
out of the tunnel oh okay yeah we're
outside okay
okay we're at the sniper scene all right
yeah yeah okay yeah yes even the sniper
scene kind of went fast like oh they
introduced this whole thing I was like
I'm wondering like okay if I was just
watching this without the game without
the game like from a I I feel like I
would feel the same way honestly
especially even in the sniper scene like
that went by pretty fast and he kind of
got up there pretty like oh this is a
problem no not really he kind of just
like right to the left and ran up no for
sure in the game it felt like not an
impossible test but you really felt the
danger of the situation not that we
didn't feel the danger here
it felt like the Avengers fighting
Ultron just felt really easy yeah that
that seemed
like he's like it's dark it's not a
problem it just it literally just like a
minute later he's up there yeah
um and so yeah there were there were
parts of this where I I did feel like
this episode for some reason that had
some the most
the times when I was most aware of the
editing yeah when I haven't had that at
all actually at all with the with the
first four episodes yeah
um so yeah this was this is the one
where I like while I love the episode
still this was the first episode of the
of the five where I was like I'm finding
some for somebody like have a little bit
of a little bit of criticisms uh for for
things or things that just didn't really
jive with me
um but yeah but we still loved it guys
that doesn't mean we didn't love it yeah
but I'm like I have some I have some
qualms and I would like to address them
in this particular episode because
that's what we're here yeah
um but yeah guys uh leave your thoughts
down below what did you think about the
episode did you think it was perfect
um did uh what what did you love what
did you not love tell us tell everyone
um last but not least uh let's end this
with a
Michael B Omni media ladies and
gentlemen I happen to know that this guy
this guy is a as a great friend of mine
and uh he's someone who I'd like to join
the reject Nation by the way I'd like
him to just be part of the channel but
he lives in Virginia so we're trying to
sort some things out that's a real thing
that we're working on putting it out
there to the public why well go check
out his channel Omni media fantastic
reaction Channel he's covering the Rocky
movies he's never seen them before I
haven't either what yep only Rocky
Balboa that's the only one I've seen
that's where you start and then you kind
of just throw out some names in a hat
and you go I guess I'm watching Rocky 3
next yeah exactly exactly
um he's doing that he's doing the last
of us and he covers a whole bunch of
things and he really knows his [__] and
so I really think that if you like if
you like reaction channels uh Michael B
is someone who I I think deserves a lot
more recognition and uh he's great at
what he does his commentary is on point
is that anything point so I would really
love it if you guys made it this far
yeah go show support to Michael B
all right guys
omnimedia is his YouTube channel it
spells it o m n one weird way to spell
it you'd be in the search more because
everyone's typing it on anyway all right
see ya
[Music]